[Musique]
une vie paradoxal joseph dadoun explore
la dualité le jour la nuit les couleurs
le noir un noir profond celui du goudron
travailler avec des outils d'ouvriers
le noir c'est c'est un point de vue de
la nuit la nuit on as le cosmos on a
notre terre qui se retrouvent dans le
noir avec la lumière de la lune
et si vous remarquez bien dans ce noir
vous vous voyez la lumière s'accroche
aux éléments donc c'est un élément
poétique et c'est aussi un sentiment
c'est ce sentiment de simplicité de
grande humilité
mais
un noir qui renvoie la terre un goudron
reflet de son passé celui d'une ville
ouvrière à la frontière avec gaza une
ville en conflit bombardé une terre
noire où poussent la vie
de là je ne pouvais que qu'avancer dans
un espoir et me projeter dans un espoir
et dans cet espoir il ya ces fleurs
et je continue à être naïf et penser
qu'à travers mon art peut-être les
cultures pourront se rapprocher et que
les deux côtés les gens feront la paix
une vision utopique assumée par
l'artiste avec sion joseph dadoun veut
sillonné la vie et le collectif
[Musique]